mark Hamill's playing a good guy allow
me to put on my skeptical it's well done
that's really like before we start it's
like let me do the opening like it's
gonna be amazing
whom maybe you do need the sweater back
why are you so mean to me I'll tell you
why because the improper use of
machinery could lead to utter
catastrophe as the code says that's not
really much of one is it until we find
out like twelve episodes later it's like
oh my god that's what it meant
this is into the bunker uh redemption
for Wendy I was gonna say sort of the
rest in peace Wendy romance which thank
God yeah is pretty welcoming and it did
work that she was a really good up in
yeah so we're done we don't need to go
back my fear was when she's like hey I
wrestled myself that was awkward and I'm
like well that'll get rule 34 yes
hopefully
I'm sure there's like pictures of like
her I know Mike is my absolute favorite
is when dipper comes up in the two of
them are wrestling and I almost wanted
to say wow this is hot
not as creepy as your internet search I
know know a dipper shaquiesha says
something like this is usually where I
wake up I was I was just watching that
unfolded I'm like oh somebody's fanfics
the crap out of this so as before this
is into the bunker they go to that tree
with the stairs around it um and they
find what they think is the author but
it turns out it's just Mark Hamill uh
straight up yeah it turns out I love
that the form he took the shape he took
the form of was actually just off of the
beans and now we know who that six
fingered glove belongs to because he
mentioned it well yeah we know it's the
author yeah the way we don't but we
still don't know who the author is we
don't know who he is but we know that
that glove cuz we were looking at that
earlier and they're like what's up with
that it's the author's one of the hand
on the journal obviously has six fingers
- um so all that stuff does I never
notice that hey no actually I really
never did you
it's impossible not to notice that I I
was looking at the numbers I don't I
told you I'm not in it for the mystery
eminent for the jokes but you can count
look it's very simple for stones for
crate zero stones zero Christ
extra points whoever gets that it's the
fifth element yeah you could count there
five of them that's fine okay I wasn't
gonna say okay so yeah you have this
episode we are dug don't hate me because
I'm having fun okay
I'll bring up the fact that you hate
waddles again there are ready
hey don't ripping you a new I don't hate
why I got my revolution with monsters
University I'm sorry these movies -
that's what I liked it
tell you what we'll end this now since
since everybody I stepped on your foot
on purpose since it why aren't you
wearing shoes cuz it's my house you
hobbit baby no I'll tell you
what we're gonna put this to rest
because everyone's going nuts because
Doug apparently hates waddles and not
hey Wow he doesn't hate waddles he's
just very indifferent to waddles and
thinks he's overrated but yeah that's
true yeah okay wait a minute so you can
make them you can kiss waddles appa
or as I like to call them WAPA kiss and
make up mm-hmm fanfic that oh okay okay
now Wow
just getting good only I get to bottom
with models wait not it Oh waddles will
water with wapa there'll be a fanfiction
Wow applause I'm gonna throw you in the
wash
what burning yikes
you know that's from a fan I'm just
wondering like that person's watching if
they're just like you know oh my god I
never thought like oh come on no effort
to fan the Greg oh my god
I rubbed against his junk I wish I could
have it back so while we get off track
yeah anywho um Oh
so sweater watch or as I'm officially
calling it swatch uh today's episode was
brought to you by the sweater light bulb
click yes and it lights up and it was
amazing um it was so uh so and we can't
explain everything you know a different
wendy break i'll put it you know it not
really got you together
yeah but um uh ml hanging about like
really i could hear all the things
you're whispering yeah it was a good to
hear that that but his reaction was
exactly mind just oh dude it's a sister
so and i like to find the play if she's
not quite like that dome because like
any one show picked up on this and stuff
um but in my paint this has the most
badass
Wendy seen it is one of my favorite
scenes it's when they're they're
fighting each other
it's just give me a sign and one smiles
of Winx and the other does the lip thing
uh and I love that scene cuz she looks
so determined and for a second you
really think the other one might be
Wendy you know because she did just sort
of change and do the wink but then like
when you see like just the badass I'm
like that was pretty cool like that's
one of those scenes were like I'm ever
somebody epic on would say like you know
don't be too hard on Wendy I'm like oh
I'm not hard on money I say actually
there's a really I said well for what my
favorite scenes is in this upcoming
episode a what oh you mean like they
knew what it is cuz it's such a badass a
they just needed time for the character
to develop and also to figure what they
wanted to do with that whole romantic
yeah I'm glad they wrapped it up and
it's one of those things were though if
this episode is something were seen it
just I didn't realize she was the
Lumberjacks daughter no near did i I had
no clue I know her family all character
makes sense I'm like huh I mean we did
see like the family before but we never
saw like the dad and now that thing
about like yeah I wonder if like what we
did see the day I was always wondering
why she was dressed like a Humber
Homer Jack Harvard um Wow my company
okay is that like I've been looking up
Wendy online or anything uh no it I was
always wondering why she was dressed up
like a lumberjack
I'm keeping uh mapo away from you this
is for me you're the one abusing one no
I'm looking up tipper ghosts at Taco
Bell and twincest I didn't I didn't look
at any that up they came to me
uh-huh no I had people on my facebook
we're just like okay oh my god the way
it has twin says I oh I was always
wondering why she was dressed up like a
lumberjack but Carlton dress like but
listen I guess lumberjack ish they
usually have red I thought it was like
some sort of Portlandia thank you yes I
same I thought yeah but now it but it
makes more sense this way mm-hmm uh so
yeah I'm trying to think of um a lot of
stuff about the mystery here in the on I
love that the the people that make the
bad buoys are called good enough
pictures um I loved that list of movies
the man with no taste attack the attack
that's you dude not funny too soon I'm
still king over my lack of taste all
right you're just actively campaigning
for the death of joy aren't you you
don't like waddles you're sitting here
making fun of me because I'm actually
having a good time with this show
you're not making fun of me yeah because
you're actively campaigning for the
death of joy I'm not I can't pay for the
death of joy but who might be is whoever
was preparing for the end down below
which I guess we know is the author it
has to be the author um at one point he
says you know they think you know at one
point he says you know I get so sick and
tired it is first time a long time since
someone that's not mold people so it's
like we could see more people uh he does
change into something else when he's
upside down at the end of the case so if
it's the author down there did he
imprison the shapeshifter was yeah
that's what he said he imprisoned the
shape say he put it date uh no danger
experiment like I think he created him
so why is he experiment uh we don't know
to fight off whatever the end is night
and we know it's gonna be like a years
and year wasn't like sixty years
something like that they did say the the
one joke that I thought maybe for a
second they were going to go there
because his office like down there his
control room looks similar to the one
grunkle stan has I thought for a sig was
gonna be this long backdoor way into
grunkle Stan's now that would have been
funny like that grunkle Stan wasn't
aware of like money somebody else built
it I have a theory I'm sure I'm not the
first one to think this I have a theory
that somehow the author is Stan um
because he did have the glove with the
six fingers I mean he does know how to
operate all that stuff I don't know what
happened to the six fingers but at the
same could've answered but but the guy
also said I've waited thirty years it's
been 30 years since I seen a one so that
would also explain again the thirty
years with Stan so so would that be
Stan's trying to figure out the
mysteries himself and that's why he's
writing the books maybe or just he was
trying to do but why did he live but
then why did he lose the third one and
then was just like oh my god it's back
and try to reactivate all the I don't
know I mean it's something much a happy
you got in a fight with whatever using
it I mean I don't know that that's my
theory for an Adam's briefcase which we
see a lot of uh in the future here it
says property of F at top of my head I
can't think of a care grunkle Stan from
coal Stan yes got it
um the layer one I can think of it I
guess I don't think is giving away too
much yet but the UH wasn't a mcgucket
would be my only or guess but it's like
I think that'd be too obvious uh because
they make him an inventor and so on so
forth
um so I don't know that that's the only
guess I have now about who the author is
but I don't know why they what would
have with the six bringing up grunkle
Stan's off as I forgot to mention this
last episode you know what I found the
most cutest thing of all the picture
yeah is that in his super secret dark
scientific II like office where you know
he's got the Stargate all of this stuff
and he's got the little picture of Mabel
and dipper there yeah that's just so
cute well I like it really shows how
much they rubbed off on me I love that
the last episode of last season where um
where they're driving off it's like you
really see the impact the kids have had
on him which I really like and again
Mabel and soos the unsung heroes like we
wouldn't have had this wrap up with this
romance I was going nowhere if it
weren't for Mabel
Suz I'm sure Plato shoved sheesh of
dipper in the closet which is its own
fanfic I'm sure but um different Mikasa
dipper in the closet goes to talk about
um different talk about closet so and
then at the very end
again the teamwork because like Wendy
and dipper were fighting it off but then
soos and Mabel froze the monster yeah
which by the way my favorite scene just
like remember that the last thing you'll
your last words or think you'll see it
will be this if you like freezes like
out and then soos is like have fun
trying to get to sleep tonight that's a
great esteem by the way it's really I
wasn't taking I love the way the so was
really dark for this show yeah and I
love how interactive version of Wendy
with an ACCI that final scene with
dipper freezing and the the
shape-shifting monster like was
legitimately for a kid show like scary
I'm like if I were kids especially ways
the attorney into if I were a kid this
would be one of those shows I would
watch like to get scared like well those
shoes like you have to break myself up
to like yeah this would be like our
Return to Oz or something like down yeah
showing this would be the show like you
can't watch you to gets a grown adult I
was like pence messed up so uh yeah good
at the zone and uh we'll just see in the
next one well you gotta hate what you
get